[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAJEEV MAHAJAN: My
name is Rajeev Mahajan
and I'm a customer engineer
in Google's retail practice.
Today, we are
going to be talking
about migrating on premises
Hadoop infrastructure
to Google Cloud Platform.
Let me introduce my
co-presenter up here.
JAMES MALONE: I'm James Malone.
I'm a product manager with
Google Cloud Platform IPM--
a couple of products.
One of them is Cloud Dataproc.
Unfortunately for
you guys, we've
hidden all of our
secret new features
in the side of the
slide deck here,
so we have a few
other presentations
today where we
will be announcing
all of our secret stuff.
So you just have
to kind of wonder
what's under the
mysterious black box there.
With that, I'm going to go ahead
and turn it over to Rajeev.
RAJEEV MAHAJAN: Thanks.
So whenever you
think about migrating
from on premises clusters
to Google Cloud Platform,
there are three aspects
that you have to consider--
migrating your infrastructure,
your data, and your jobs.
And that's what we are
going to talk about today.
OK.
There are a few recommendations
we are going to make,
and we are going to stress
them over and over again
in this presentation,
and they are as follows.
First, when you are thinking
about infrastructure,
we highly encourage you to look
at other Google Cloud Platform
services that will really make
running your clusters very
economical and very efficient.
Second, we want you to
consider migrating from HDFS
to Google Cloud Storage.
And we'll talk
about why and how.
Third, we want to,
again, encourage
you to consider something
called ephemeral clusters.
Ephemeral clusters are
job specific clusters,
as contrasted to general
purpose clusters that
run multiple jobs in a
shared cluster environment.
So we want to encourage
you to think about those,
and we are again going
to talk a lot about them.
So that's the general
outline of this presentation.
Let's get the most important
things out of the way very,
very quickly.
What are the benefits of
migrating to Google Cloud
Platform?
And consider the fact that I'm
saying Google Cloud Platform.
I am not saying
Google Cloud Dataproc.
There is a reason for that.
So let's see what that means.
First, Google Cloud
Dataproc, which
is what you will be migrating
to, is a cloud service.
So you get pay as you go and
you get vast and varied scale.
Make sense?
Second, it is a managed service.
We provision the VMs for you, we
provision the clusters for you,
we deploy operating
systems on them,
and we deploy the open source
stack on these nodes, which
means that you
don't have to do it
and you don't have to carry
the administrative overhead
to do it.
Third, if you think
about Cloud Dataproc,
that is Google's implementation
of the open source Hadoop
infrastructure.
Let me define Cloud Dataproc
as we talk about it internally.
Cloud Dataproc is
a managed service
to run your Spark
and Hadoop jobs.
That's what it is.
If you're trying to migrate from
your on-premise clusters, which
are running that
open source stack,
it's very easy to
do that by just
making some minor
modifications to your job core.
If that's all you
are looking to do--
you are focused on a lift and
shift strategy right now--
it's very simple to do that.
But I think where you get value
is when you start implementing
our recommendations that
we've just talked about,
and I am going to kind of
elaborate on what that value
proposition is.
OK.
The next two-- four and five--
really are about
Google Cloud Platform.
They are not about
Google Cloud Dataproc.
We just talked about running
ephemeral clusters, which
are job specific
clusters, and what
we are trying to stress there
is rather than deploying
a whole bunch of libraries
for running Hadoop and Spark
and Hive and whatever else
that you can think of,
we just want you to focus
on the job of interest.
That means you do not have
library clashes, et cetera,
et cetera.
The management overhead
is low and it really
greases the wheels of your
operations really, really well.
Make sense?
Finally, Hadoop
has a blind spot,
and the blind spot is
when you are working
with persistent
data, it is in HDFS
and it is not very
easy to go and unlock
the value of that data and
move it to other platforms
where the value
really gets used.
Let me establish a
very simple use case.
Say you just ran a Spark
job and the Spark job
was creating recommendations for
powering your personalization
engine on your website.
How do you get that data
that your Spark job just
generated, which is
stored in HDFS, out
to your recommendation engine?
That is a challenge, and
we, with our whole plethora
of different services,
actually do that really well.
And we are going to
talk about this--
a couple of
different points, OK.
Let's get started.
Section number 1,
just-- you're going
to focus on infrastructure.
Let's step back.
Let's look at our
on-premise clusters.
There are three
characteristics which stand out
for these on-premise clusters.
One, they're monolithic and they
have a large number of nodes
that you need to make
sure get upgraded
and have the right
software in tandem.
If you don't do that,
you'll have trouble,
and you know all that.
Second, these are persistent.
They run for many
days, which means
it leads to other kinds
of management overhead
with making sure that
everything-- all the job
configuration is right and
there are no clashes and nothing
has died and everything is up.
Third, these clusters are shared
across jobs, teams, projects,
and that sharing
infrastructure leads
to a whole bunch of
different problems
that you are probably
very aware of.
I'm not going to focus on that.
We're going to talk about
how to solve these problems.
The key characteristic
which creates
a lot of problems with
on-premise clusters
is the fact that they are
persistent and they are shared.
And we just talked about
data being locked in HDFS,
and we need to figure
out a way to unlock that.
So that's one limitation.
Second, HDFS, because of
its replication factor--
2, 3, 4-- I don't know what
you guys are running with--
it's expensive.
Third, if you are not using
Google Cloud Platform,
you have an opportunity cost.
What is that opportunity cost?
You cannot use other services
that can help unlock the value
inside your clusters.
Make sense?
Let's look at some
solutions now.
Very simple diagram--
first of many.
Your on-premise
cluster is on the left
and your migrated
clusters are on the right.
On-premise, you are running
two clusters, four jobs,
and two HDFS setups.
When you are done
migrating, you will actually
have three clusters--
job three and four actually
get their own clusters.
Remember, I've been talking
about ephemeral clusters, which
are job specific, which
means one cluster per job.
So I got three clusters
running and all my data
is stored in Google
Cloud Storage buckets.
So remember, I said
migrate from HDFS to GCS.
Use ephemeral clusters.
This is that architecture.
Very simple.
Basic.
We are going to build on this,
but this is our starting point.
Now before we actually
delve even deeper,
let's talk about
two very important
architectural principles that
are embedded in Google Cloud
Dataproc, and our
migration recommendations
aligned really, really well with
those architectural principles.
The first
architectural principle
is separate your data
from computation.
Now this particular
architectural principle
is not unique to Cloud Dataproc.
Pretty much all of
Google's big data platform
and different offerings--
BigQuery et cetera--
they are built
on this architectural principle.
Now how that translates
into specific things
you need to do with Cloud
Dataproc-- that follows.
First, we are asking you to
migrate from HDFS to GCS.
That's your separation.
Separate the data
out from the cluster.
Remove it from HDFS.
GCS is HDFS
compliant, which means
that it's only slight
modifications you need
to make to your code,
and we will actually
show you what those are and you
are running in Cloud Dataproc.
But as I said earlier, if
all you are looking to do
is to do a lift and shift,
it's a very simple thing.
But if you trying
to get value, we
will go and talk
about other things.
Second, GCS is faster, GCS is
definitely more economical,
and GCS is very easy to manage--
little to no
management overhead.
And we already
talked about the fact
that if you are looking to
unlock value within HDFS,
and if you move
to GCS, the way it
works is most of
Google Cloud Platform
technologies work very
seamlessly with Google Cloud
Storage, which means
that is your venue.
That is your door
to opening the value
from within Cloud from
your on-premise clusters
in Cloud Dataproc.
Make sense?
Let's talk about the second
architectural principle,
which I've already
talked about three times
and I'm going to talk
about 10 times more.
Use ephemeral clusters.
Now, if you have jobs sharing
the same infrastructure,
you have to do a setup
before every job run.
You have to make sure
that the configuration
for the cluster for
that particular job run
is set up right.
That's quite a bit of
management overhead.
If I actually am
now running clusters
which are job specific,
I don't have to do that.
I just have to configure
that particular job.
I also don't have to
deploy a whole bunch
of different libraries.
So if I'm running a Spark job,
I don't need to deploy Hadoop
libraries or Hive libraries.
Make sense?
Easier to manage.
The easiest analogy I can
think about this architectural
principle is that old
proverb that you've heard.
Fire is a very poor
master, but a great slave,
or some variation of that.
Clusters, because of
all the limitations
we talked about earlier, are
actually running you ragged
in most cases.
We are trying to relieve that
pressure by taking control
back over our clusters through
the ephemeral cluster design.
Make sense?
It's logical, right?
Now what do you get with this?
First thing that you
get is the ability
to have very controlled
configurations--
much finer control
over the jobs.
Second is I can actually
scale my cluster independently
off any other job that I might
be sharing in a shared cluster
architecture.
So I could deploy 1,000
nodes for one job,
whereas my cluster itself
was 100 nodes earlier.
Huge value unlocking.
Let's keep going.
Job specific cluster.
How does it work?
I start my job through Cloud
Dataproc API or through the UI.
It doesn't matter.
It spins up a cluster for you,
which you configured earlier.
The job runs.
It generates data.
In this case, I'm
actually outputting data
to Google BigQuery--
Cloud BigQuery.
And we'll talk about
why that is so.
I also am storing
data in Cloud Storage.
I run my job, and once
the job is complete,
I actually delete the cluster.
I delete the cluster.
Can you believe it?
Because this is a problem.
We talked about this
diagram earlier.
That was our simple
starting point.
Life is never simple.
Simple diagrams don't actually
do justice to the problems
we have to face
in the real world.
Let's build on
this a little bit.
This is my migration end state--
the cloud-native solution.
On the left, in green, you
see my ephemeral clusters.
We just talked about them.
Job specific.
I can have a bunch of them.
I don't need 1, 2, 3.
I could have hundreds of
them if need be, as required.
In the middle, in blue, you
see my different data stores.
I already talked
about Cloud Storage.
I'm adding two more to this mix.
It's BigQuery and Bigtable.
BigQuery, for those of you
who do not know about it,
is a terabyte scale
data warehouse,
and Bigtable is really
about managing sparse data
that you want to read and
write to very, very fast.
Very low latency read
and write access.
Both of those are
now available for me.
Remember, I was
talking about unlocking
that value stored in HDFS.
That's what we are doing.
We also are talking about
monitoring and logging.
Get a little bit better
idea of your operations
and what you need to tune as you
actually get data from runtime.
Below my ephemeral clusters,
you see an orchestration engine.
You see Apache Airflow.
Apache Airflow or a
variant like an Azkaban--
that's what you can
implement for coordinating
the flow of your jobs
and their dependencies.
We actually have
recently GA'd a product
called Google Cloud Composer
and James has a very, very big
section in the afternoon today.
You want to give some
details about that session?
JAMES MALONE: Yeah, so
there's a session at 1:55
on our GA launch of
Cloud Composer, which
is a managed Apache
Airflow service.
And the goal with having
a managed Apache Airflow
service is to solve
the cloud level
workflows and orchestrations,
but have a product that's
open source that can talk
to things inside of Google,
talk to things
outside of Google.
In that session,
we'll be talking
about why we launched
Composer, kind of our vision
for Composer.
If you're new to
Airflow, we'll be
breaking apart an Airflow DAG
and giving a demo of Composer.
So it's a good kind
of baseline and intro
to Airflow and Cloud
Composer, if you're curious.
And it's at 1:55 today, and
I think it's not quite full,
but it is almost at capacity.
So if you're curious,
do sign up for it.
RAJEEV MAHAJAN: OK.
And now, in yellow,
on the right--
yellow or orange--
whatever you're seeing--
I have persistent clusters.
What?
Didn't I just tell
you that you need
to go over the ephemeral
clusters stateless,
and I'm telling you you need
to have persistent clusters
in this architecture?
Life is complex.
We'll talk about it in
a couple of seconds.
Say you have a
Spark streaming job.
Running it on an ephemeral
cluster is next to impossible.
You need a persistent cluster.
You may also have
a use case where
you have a bunch of different
jobs that need to run together.
They're dependent on each
other, and some of these jobs
actually are very short run.
They might just be ingesting
data into the cluster itself
or into GCS from a source.
The overhead of
spinning up a cluster
might be much larger than
you want to tolerate.
That's also a good
case for running
maybe a short and
persistent cluster,
but a persistent
cluster, none the less.
Make sense?
But if you are going to
run a persistent cluster,
here are a couple
of recommendations.
Number one, scope it to be
the smallest possible cluster
that you can think of, in
terms of number of jobs
you're going to run and the
number of nodes that are going
to be part of that cluster.
It's a very, very
simple recommendation.
So we talked about the
underlying components,
we talked about
architectural principles.
Let's get to the mechanics.
First, move data to GCS.
Again, I'm repeating it again.
Do it incrementally, and we'll
actually talk about a couple
of strategies in a
couple of minutes.
Second thing is experiment.
What does that mean?
Now that I have actually opened
up the architecture for you,
I can run job specific
ephemeral clusters.
I want you to run
proofs of concept.
I want you to experiment with
the size of your cluster,
the number of nodes--
try out different
configurations.
Figure out what works best for
you, in terms of the dollars
that you are
spending, the time it
takes to run a particular
job, because that's
a requirement in many cases.
I want to go from 12
hours to two hours.
That's my new window.
You can experiment
and you can actually
make it happen with
Cloud Dataproc.
So that's our recommendation.
Central to all of this
is ephemeral clusters,
which we have been talking
about over and over again.
Migrating incrementally.
OK, so what's new?
Anybody who has been
in the world of IT
thinks in terms of eating
the elephant in small chunks,
right?
The only guidance up here
is when you are actually
creating POCs or you're defining
the scope of your Agile Sprint,
if that's your thing,
then think in terms
of dependencies of the jobs.
Move them together.
It will actually make
things simple for you.
Remember, what ephemeral
clusters are are stateless.
You have input,
you have output--
there's nothing inside
the cluster, itself.
It runs, it dies, it
rises up like the Phoenix,
and it dies again.
The cycle of birth
and rebirth keeps
on going on with an
ephemeral cluster, right?
Think incrementally.
Let's take, actually, a
look at an architecture
which will help you do that.
This architecture is something
called a backfill pipeline.
Are you guys aware of this?
Have you ever heard of this?
Anybody?
Yes?
OK.
So say you have your
big data stack running
for the last three years.
Recently, in the last
six months or so,
you created a bunch of new jobs.
But since your cluster is
already running to capacity,
you'll never have the
time to go back and run
these jobs against your archive
data from 2 and 1/2 years ago.
The idea of a backfill pipeline
is to actually take your jobs
and run it against archive data.
So how is that relevant to us?
Remember, I've been
saying experiment.
Using your jobs-- the
newly migrated jobs--
against archive data is
actually a very good way
of validating that your
jobs will run well,
they will run correct, and you
will get the characteristics
you are looking for, in
terms of performance,
times, et cetera, et cetera.
Make sense?
So this is one low
risk architecture.
The key component up
here is that little box
in the middle, which says
internet gateway and cloud
storage.
We are trying to bring data over
from your on-premise cluster
into Cloud Dataproc.
That's the key idea
there, and are actually
going to expand on this
a little bit further, OK?
So you are in the
middle of a migration.
Before migration, you had
your on-premise cluster.
After migration, you have
that cloud-native architecture
I talked about.
Somewhere in the middle, both
of them are living together.
That's the idea behind
hybrid architecture.
Nothing new there.
Now this hybrid architecture
we just talked about
is being imposed on you by
the requirements of being
in the middle of
a migration cycle,
but there might be business
requirements for you
to actually have a
hybrid architecture.
I'll give you an example.
One of my customers is actually
running their order management
system on-premise.
They're looking to
migrate it to the cloud,
but the problem is it's going
to take a little bit of time
for them to figure out
what that looks like.
It's a monolithic system.
They need to figure
out how to create
micro services, et
cetera, et cetera,
and do that
appropriate migration.
So they want to, for
the foreseeable future,
run their extraction
and big data
jobs relating to order
management system in-house.
That's the hybrid architecture
we are talking about.
Example, again, ephemeral
clusters in green on the left.
We have the storage
in blue and we have
on-premise yellow on the right.
And in the middle
is a contraption
for bringing your data over
from your on-premise clusters
over into Cloud Storage.
VPN gateways are involved
and some more clusters
are involved.
Now these clusters are for
actually copying the data over
from your on-premise cluster
over to cloud storage.
There are a couple
of mechanisms there.
It's really out of the scope of
this particular presentation,
but we will point you
to a couple of links
where you can actually go and
take a closer look at them.
And maybe this is something
where you actually
engage Google professional
services to help you with.
OK.
There's a push and pull kind
of an architecture involved.
Of the three recommendations
I gave you in the beginning,
the first one was look
at a broader portfolio
of Google Cloud Services.
Let's talk about what are
the considerations there.
Regions.
Say you are deploying
new architecture.
It's a multi-regional
architecture,
and for some reason, your
persistent data in Google Cloud
Storage is sitting in a region
which is separate from where
your resources are located--
your ephemeral clusters
are located, et cetera.
What is probably going
to happen for you
is Google Cloud is probably
going to, in certain cases,
copy the data over from
one region to another.
There are latency
considerations and there
are cost considerations
because of egress costs,
and you need to think
through some of that,
especially if you are building
any kind of DR kind of a setup.
OK.
All Google Cloud services
have Stackdriver logging
and monitoring built into them.
You can use your
on-premise or whatever tool
you are using to
bring that data,
or you can actually
use Stackdriver.
We think it's
pretty cool, so you
should stay with Stackdriver,
but it's your choice.
Finally, I have talked
about this multiple times--
we can store data in BigQuery
and in Bigtable as needed.
Section 2.
So we've talked
about infrastructure.
Let's talk very
quickly about data.
We've been through
this a few times.
You can migrate data from
Apache HBase to Bigtable--
equivalent technologies.
You can migrate data from
Apache Impala to BigQuery,
and, if you've got
Hive running, you
may want to think about running
your Hive metastore on Cloud
SQL, which is Google's open
source implementation of mySQL.
Make sense?
Security.
You are never going to get
the level of granular control
that you get in HDFS, but
using Google's IAM policies,
you can have equivalent
control over the data that is
stored in Google Cloud Storage.
We are recommending
that you apply controls
at the level of buckets,
not at the level of files.
But if, for some
reason, your use case
requires that you work
at the level of a file,
then think in terms
of using GCS ACLs.
We don't recommend it, but if
you have to go down that path,
you have to go down that path.
Make sense?
Speed.
I process terabytes
of data per data,
and my VPN connection
is not fast enough
or doesn't have
enough bandwidth.
What do I do?
So some people deploy
multiple VPN connections.
That might solve
the problem for you,
depending on the volume of
data you are working with.
Or you may want to look at
two alternative technologies
to plug into Google's network--
Direct Peering.
Have you guys been familiar
with Direct Peering?
Anybody deploy it?
Direct Peering is
essentially your ability
to tap into Google's
fast network directly
through the point of presence--
what do we call them?
POPs?
POP setups.
If you are unable to
do that for any reason,
you can actually use
our partner services
called Cloud
Interconnect services,
where a partner actually lays
the cable from their data
center, which is kind
of located and connects
into Google network.
And you can broaden
that bandwidth.
Make sense?
So these are the key
elements for data.
It's bandwidth,
it's access control,
and where you are storing data.
Let's talk about jobs.
Remember, the first
thing I said was
if all you are looking
to do is to migrate
your jobs from on-premise
to Cloud Dataproc,
it's very, very simple to do.
HDFS-- those four letters--
you replace it with
those two letters, GS.
That's all you need to do.
It's pretty cool, huh?
We support-- these
come as default setups,
but we are not limited to
actually supporting these.
So we have something called
initialization actions,
where you can define what
kind of stack you want to run,
and it will add runtime,
deploy the stack for you,
and you can continue
with your running
that particular stack or jobs.
So these are just the
default configurations
available to you, but
initialization actions lets you
open up the whole stack, right?
JAMES MALONE: That's correct.
Something that's
not on here that's
a feature that we are
releasing in the next few weeks
is the ability to
also pick and choose
which components you would
like on your cluster.
So canonically right now,
when you create a cluster,
you can specify one or more
initialization actions.
And those initialization actions
are shell scripts or anything
that can be executed in
a Debian environment.
People have asked
for the ability
to do things like tick a box.
So I want a cluster
with Spark and maybe add
Zeppelin or HBase.
So in the coming
weeks, you'll see
when you create a
Dataproc cluster,
there'll be additional options
and you just say, create
a cluster with Zeppelin,
Anaconda, Livy,
whatever else you want.
That makes it easier
to create the cluster
with the optional components.
It also means, on
the back end, we're
testing all of those components
against each Dataproc image
build.
That's probably a
session in and of itself
because how we build the
image is really interesting,
but quite a lengthy process.
But it also means that we're
testing all of those components
against our weekly image builds
to make sure that they work--
that things don't break with
each new release of Debian,
each new release of the
open source components
and all of their dependencies,
which can be quite complicated.
So it's abstracting
away quite a bit
of that complexity
for you so you
don't have to worry about it.
RAJEEV MAHAJAN: The
key point I wanted
to actually bubble up
in this particular slide
are two things.
One, as you migrate from
your on-premise cluster
over to ephemeral
clusters, you may
want to start with the smallest
possible configuration that
is closest to what
you were running with,
and then do the experiments.
You might find that even
with a smaller configuration,
you might get
equivalent performance.
You'll be surprised there.
The second point
I wanted to make
was this point about preemptible
instances or preemptible
workers.
Preemptible workers is
really a cool feature,
wherein you can take
discounts of up to 80%
on the regular pricing
on instances that Google,
if needed be, can reclaim
back by telling you
that we are actually
claiming these instances.
But if not, you can run some
of your higher latency jobs--
something that is not critical
at a lower price point.
They are very,
very cool features.
Final piece is all
about scalability.
Cloud Dataproc allows you
to scale both up and down,
and we also have this concept
of graceful degradation.
So we actually let
the cluster figure out
that it's ready to
scale up or down--
usually down at the right
moment without crashing nodes
and creating problems for you.
Last piece in this
is restartable jobs.
Dataproc also has
the intelligence
to figure out if a job
has actually completed
or it was aborted for a
plethora of different reasons.
Maybe some services
were not available
or you had some
dependencies that you
couldn't do anything about.
So you may want to think
about building your jobs
or modifying them slightly,
so they are restartable.
Make sense?
For longer running jobs--
say a Spark job that
runs for 20 hours or so,
what you may want to do
is use preemptible instances,
but build in your own variation
of checkpointing in it.
So at the appropriate time, save
the data into Cloud Storage,
and if, for some reason,
the instances get preempted
and you have to
restart, you still
haven't lost 15 hours
of work that you did.
It's not complicated to do.
It's very simple, and if any of
you guys want to talk about it,
we can do that offline.
Make sense?
Now you've got the
migration done.
We are wanting to run
this on an ongoing basis.
What you may want to do
is to apply custom labels
for identifying your
clusters, cost charge backs,
et cetera, et cetera.
This is just a basic feature
built into all of Google Cloud
Platform.
We've already talked
about organizing
GCS buckets to separate jobs
and applying access controls.
And finally, we've talked
about ephemeral clusters
and the ability to run one
or closely related jobs
on the same cluster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]